Bob saga's memory lives on in the latest
episode of The Masked Singer that truly
tugged at our heartstrings yeah did it
ever the reality competition show
celebrated a small screen with its TV
theme night featuring heartfelt
performances and some iconic theme songs
including one of my personal favorites
everywhere he looks from Whole House
such a great song the fortune teller and
the harp based off in a vocal Showdown
each delivering their own rendition of
the theme song Take a look
everywhere
there's a face
[Music]
there's a place
[Music]
[Music]
everywhere you look everywhere you go
I mean I'm speechless that's just so
beautiful it was the harps Soulful and
emotional delivery that brought judge
Ken Jeong and the audience to tears
especially with Full House star Jody
Sweetin in the crowd serving as a guest
on this week's episode
wow Full House
just took us to the full Church
whoa what a battle Ken are you are you
tearing up there are those real tears I
tell you watching you sing that harp and
seeing Jody uh somewhere up above
our friends quickly monster Bob Saget is
smiling I just want to say
love you so much this is what TV is all
about it unites amazing amazing
oh so such an honest reaction and you
know I was looking this up too so
squiggly monster was uh the caution that
Bob Saget wore for season three four and
if you haven't seen him before on the
perform on the show I was just looking
at clips and he did an amazing rendition
of ccr's uh have you ever seen the rain
and I was actually really impressed with
how good is singing voice is yeah it's
just beautiful the harp uh everyone
thinks it's Amber Riley from Glee The
Voice come on I mean I started just the
way she performed that song and their
steps standing on the side
it is emotional and you know if you see
her performance for Whitney Houston you
have to watch I was telling you to watch
it because I was crying because that
voice is so beautiful but you know Bob
Saga we lost him at such a young age at
65 earlier this year so you know I could
see the emotions you know especially for
Ken but the fact that he was on the show
just it's a full circle it makes sense
right obviously there's a closeness
there uh both being comedians to such
respect in the industry and just in
general girl I mean this is Bob Saget
also just as a human being but his
character on Full House I mean so
recognizable all around the world just
that theme song brings me like the warm
and fuzzies it was such a huge part of
my childhood so he is right when he says
TV really can unite people yeah TV theme
songs they can get you